When your name is Dan, you get a lot of nicknames. Growing up in Harlem, Daniel Day heard his fair share of them. Sometimes I go back to my old neighborhood on the east side where everybody calls me the anyboy. But the sober K that would stick, the one most people would come to know was Dapper Dan. Because from a young age, he'd like to look good. Clothes was aapper Dan. Because from a young age, he liked to look good. Clothes was a transformative thing.
当你的名字叫丹时，你会得到很多绰号。在哈莱姆长大的丹尼尔·戴（Daniel Day）听过不少这样的绰号。有时我回到东区的老邻居那里，每个人都叫我“任何人”。但那个会留下来、让大多数人知道的冷静的 K 是 Dapper Dan。因为从小他就喜欢打扮得体。衣服是。Dapper Dan。因为从小他就喜欢打扮得体。衣服是。一件具有变革意义的事。
If you got dressed, you got really dressed up and you went downtown, nobody knew you came from the forest, maybe it didn't follow. That's what made a difference. People of color, when you dress, that has an equalizing effect on how you feel, especially if you can dress better in the white kids that you see.
如果你盛装打扮，真正盛装打扮然后去闹市区，没有人知道你是从森林里出来的，也许它并没有跟上。这就是不同之处。有色人种，当你穿衣时，这对你的感觉有一种平衡的作用，特别是如果你能比你看到的白人小孩穿得更好。
Dapper Dan's life took a lot of crazy turns, including, but not limited to, years of running street bets and dice games, a ring of credit card fraud, an arrest and a ruba, time in prison. He was a hustler and a gambler for decades. But what he's best known for is what he did after all that. When he decided to get away from his life of crime Sort of when I didn't want to be involved in other other games us in the street games negative street game. I look for something else to do the year was 1980 Dan was in his late 30s since I knew all the people who liked the dress and the ones who had the money I said that would be a great opportunity for me and I knew that that door would be open for me. Dapper Dan wanted to get into the fashion game to live up to his honorific.
Dapper Dan 的生活经历了很多疯狂的转折，包括但不限于多年经营街头赌博和骰子游戏、信用卡诈骗团伙、一次逮捕和抢劫以及监狱服刑。几十年来，他一直是个骗子和赌徒。但他最著名的却是这一切之后的事情。当他决定远离犯罪生活时……当我不愿参与其他街头游戏、负面街头游戏时。我寻找别的事可做，那年是 1980 年，丹快 40 岁了。既然我认识所有喜欢穿衣的人和那些有钱的人，我说这对我会是一个很好的机会，而且我知道这扇门会为我敞开。Dapper Dan 想要进入时尚界，以无愧于他的尊称。
But he had to start somewhere so he started selling stolen clothes. I did a back-and-forth call, used call. I go around to all the hustlers, all the spots where they be at, all the street people. And you got a real taste for the kinds of fashions people in Harlem we're looking for. Dan's clients wanted color and flair and personality. Of a dark Eurocentric stuff you'd find in a Madison Avenue boutique. So you want real soul fly stuff? You want to get into that gritty soul look. You got to come to a real gritty soul guy. So, Dapper Dan saved up money and opened a shop in 1982. He hired
但他必须从某个地方开始，所以他开始出售偷来的衣服。我来回打电话，用呼叫。我走遍所有骗子、他们出现的所有地方以及所有的街头人员。你对哈莱姆人正在寻找的时尚有了真正的品味。丹的客户想要色彩、气势和个性。不同于你在麦迪逊大道精品店里能找到的那些黑暗的欧洲中心主义的东西。所以你想要真正有灵魂的东西？你想融入那种粗犷的灵魂外观。你必须去找一个真正粗犷的灵魂人物。于是，Dapper Dan 攒下钱，于 1982 年开了一家店。他雇用了
tailors and seamstresses and created custom furs and leather goods for his clients making whatever they wanted. Dapper Dan and his tailors were pretty dynamic. He didn't have any one signature look or style. That was until one day when one of the most popular hustlers in Harlem marched into Dan's shop. He came into the store one day and he had a Louis Vuitton pouch. And it was full of $100 bills. So everybody was looking at it. Everybody got excited about it. But everyone was ignoring the hundred dollar bills. And he got excited about the bag itself. And I looked at that bag and I said, why are they excited? It's only five hours with vinyl. I know all about it. But it was the symbols
裁缝和女裁缝，为客户定制皮草和皮革制品，根据他们的要求制作任何东西。Dapper Dan 和他的裁缝们非常具有活力。他没有任何标志性的造型或风格。直到有一天，哈莱姆最受欢迎的骗子之一大步走进了丹的店铺。有一天他走进店里，手里拿着一个路易威登（Louis Vuitton）的小袋。里面装满了 100 美元钞票。所以每个人都在看着它。每个人都为此兴奋不已。但每个人都忽略了一百美元的钞票。他对外面的包本身感到兴奋。我看着那个包说，他们为什么兴奋？这只是五小时的乙烯基。我对此了如指掌。但它是符号
on the bag. Those little Ls and Vs and Quattro foils all over that Louis Vuitton bag. And in that moment, Dapper Dan came up with an idea that would turn fashion upside down. A bulb went off in my head. Oh! And his idea was to take those symbols on that bag and steal them. Articles of interest. A show about what we wear. Season 2.
包上的。那些小 L、V 和四叶饰遍布整个路易威登包。就在那一刻，Dapper Dan 有了一个将时尚颠覆的想法。我脑光一闪。哦！他的想法是把包上的那些符号偷走。感兴趣的物品。关于我们穿什么的节目。第二季。
People don't realize it's fantasy. It's always this thing that you have to work extra hard to get. Mmm, that's so good. No one dresses like a king anymore. How do you make money? That's how I make money, love. There are lots of things that we take for granted that would once have been considered luxuries.
人们没有意识到这是一种幻想。这总是一种你必须付出额外努力才能得到的东西。嗯，太棒了。再也没有人像国王那样穿衣了。你是怎么赚钱的？我就是这样赚钱的，亲爱的。有很多我们认为理所当然的事情，曾经被认为是奢侈品。
Sometimes, if I'm passing through downtown San Francisco, or Manhattan, or in an airport, or in a mall, I'll look around and I'll take stock of the retail landscape. Massive posters of poorless, dough-eyed faces stare down at me, advertising handbags that cost double my rent. And sometimes I look around and I'm just like, Who is this for? Who could possibly afford all this? How is there enough money around to keep all these brands in business and their flagship stores around the world? Who is impulsively buying a $2,000 Burberry coat wilting in an airport boutique?
有时，如果我路过旧金山市中心、曼哈顿、机场或购物中心，我会环顾四周，盘点一下零售格局。毫无表情、天真无邪的面孔巨幅海报俯视着我，宣传着价格是我房租两倍的手提包。有时我环顾四周，心里想，这是给谁准备的？究竟谁能买得起这一切？怎么会有这么多的钱来维持所有这些品牌及其在世界各地的旗舰店的经营？谁会在机场精品店里冲动购买一件价值 2000 美元的巴宝莉（Burberry）外套？
Who is stumbling into a protestor front to try on a dress? Who is this for? Turns out, this is for you. The point isn't to make money. The point is to build up a brand and an identity that then will sell the things that do make money which are usually accessories that are relatively cheap. So everything from shoes, handbags, on down to little wallets and sunglasses and whatever. UCLA Law Professor Karl Rastiala says that the lux advertisements, the intimidating shops,
谁会闯入示威者的前台试穿一件衣服？这是给谁用的？事实证明，这适合你。重点不是赚钱。重点是建立一个品牌和一个身份，然后出售那些确实能赚钱的东西，这些通常是相对便宜的配饰。所以从鞋子、手提包，一直到小钱包和太阳镜等等。加州大学洛杉矶分校法学教授卡尔·拉斯蒂阿拉（Karl Raustiala）说，奢侈品的广告、令人生畏的商店，
and to a degree, the runway shows are about building up the mythology of a brand so that they can sell their logo on other stuff. Kouture often operates primarily to build a brand and runway shows do that as well. A lot of stuff that goes on the runways never sees the light of day in a store. It's about the performance of a brand, the creation of a story. Because for the right name, the right symbol, we will buy something not in spite of its price, but because of it. So normally we think supply and demand, kind of driven by price, and that the cheap or
并在某种程度上，时装秀是为了建立品牌的神秘感，以便他们可以在其他东西上销售他们的标志。高级时装（Kouture）通常主要用于打造品牌，时装秀也能做到这一点。很多在T台上展示的东西永远不会在商店里重见天日。这是关于品牌的表现、故事的创作。因为对于正确的名字、正确的符号，我们买东西不是尽管它的价格，而是因为它的价格。所以通常我们认为供求关系是由价格驱动的，而且越便宜
something gets, more people are going to consume it. That's true for most things. If those like gas is cheaper, people are going to drive more. That's normal goods. Fabling goods are as they get more expensive. People are drawn to it. Fabling goods are named for Torsten Fablin. Fablin was an economist way back in the distant past. 121 years ago, it would be more precise. Who talked about the fact that some things are more attractive than more expensive they are. And certain things actually, the very cost of them
东西得到了，更多的人会消费它。对于大多数事情来说都是如此。如果像天然气这样更便宜，人们就会开车更多。那是普通商品。凡勃伦商品（Veblen goods）是指随着它们变得越来越贵。人们被它吸引。凡勃伦商品是以托斯坦·凡勃伦（Thorstein Veblen）的名字命名的。凡勃伦是遥远过去的经济学家。准确地说，是 121 年前。他谈到了这样一个事实：有些东西越贵，就越有吸引力。事实上，某些东西，其成本本身
are part of their appeal. Luxury is almost like the quantum physics of economics. We're all the established laws of supply and demand to just go out the window. That's true for a lot of things in the fashion world because fashion is so often about both self-expression but also about excluding others and showing that you have high status. So the more expensive and unattainable they are, the better. And the more expensive and unattainable they are,
是其吸引力的一部分。奢侈品几乎就像经济学的量子力学。我们所有的既定供求规律都烟消云散了。对于时尚界的许多事情来说，这都是事实，因为时尚往往既关乎自我表达，也关乎排斥他人并展示你拥有高地位。所以它们越贵越高不可攀，就越好。它们越昂贵、越遥不可及，
the more likely it is that someone is going to knock them off. someone is going to knock them off. As Chinatown descends into the financial district, all along Canal Street in Manhattan, people will approach you clad in black baseball caps holding up laminated sheets of paper. And these laminated bits of paper are basically menus showing the variety of knock-off handbags they're pedaling. How much for number 21? That one? Yeah. 100 dollar, nice to collect. Yeah? You collect.
别人效仿的可能性就越大。别人会模仿他们。随着唐人街向金融区延伸，沿着曼哈顿的卡纳尔街（Canal Street），人们会穿着黑色棒球帽走近你，手里拿着层压纸页。这些层压纸基本上是菜单，展示了他们兜售的各种山寨手提包。21号多少钱？那个？是的。100美元，很好收集。是的？你收集。
Maybe this is if you do no one, they'll go 400 dollar. When you point to a bag on the laminated menu, your dealer will go fetch it from a storeroom nearby. This convoluted system helps the sellers keep a low profile, although there are also some bold vendors who just put their wares right there on the sidewalk. And here's like a velvet Gucci bag. It's actually extremely cute. The street vendors lay their bags on a big sheet so that they can pull up the corners and run away when they see the police coming. This is of course a legal. Anytime you're copying a brand, a trademark, a course, illegal. Anytime you're copying a brand, a trademark, a logo,
也许如果你不认识，他们会出价 400 美元。当你指向层压菜单上的包时，你的经销商会从附近的储藏室取回它。这种错综复杂的系统有助于卖家保持低调，尽管也有一些大胆的供应商直接将商品摆在人行道上。这里有一个天鹅绒古驰（Gucci）包。其实非常可爱。街头小贩将他们的包放在一张大纸上，这样当他们看到警察来时就可以拉起四个角逃跑。这当然是合法的。任何复制品牌、商标、课程的行为都是非法的。任何复制品牌、商标、logo 的行为，
you're breaking the law. A logo is protectable by law. That's true of any two-dimensional image or drawing or pattern or print. So if the print is actually original to you, it's not in the public domain. It's like a two-dimensional image. You can protect that.
你触犯了法律。标志受法律保护。任何二维图像、绘图、图案或印花都是如此。因此，如果该印花实际上是您原创的，则它不属于公共领域。就像二维图像一样。你可以保护它。
This is, in part, why many luxury brands started to pattern their logos all over their handbags in the first place. It's like watermarking an image to try to protect it. But like any illegal trade, these knockoffs don't exist in a bubble. Taurus flocked to Canal Street from all over the world to buy these knockoff handbags, knowing full well they are knockoffs.
这也是许多奢侈品牌最初开始在手提包上到处印上标志的部分原因。这就像给图像添加水印以试图保护它。但就像任何非法贸易一样，这些山寨货并不是孤立存在的。来自世界各地的游客蜂拥至卡纳尔街购买这些山寨手提包，他们心知肚明这些是山寨货。
Like if these shoppers really needed handbags, they could get high quality unbranded ones for the same price somewhere else. They come to Canal Street for these powerful symbols. Dapper Dan witnessed the power of these symbols on that fateful day back in the 80s. When that one hustler in Harlem walled into his shop with that vinyl Louis Vuitton pouch, and everyone gathered around the little bag transfixed. That's when Dapper Dan thought, Okay, if they had fascinating with those symbols, how about if I have them walking around looking like that bag?
就像这些购物者如果真的需要手提包，他们可以在别处以相同的价格买到高质量的无品牌手提包。他们来到卡纳尔街是为了这些强大的符号。Dapper Dan 在 80 年代那个命运般的日子里目睹了这些符号的力量。当哈莱姆的那位骗子拿着那个乙烯基路易威登袋走进他的店里时，每个人都聚集在那个小袋周围惊呆了。就在那时，Dapper Dan 想，好吧，如果他们对这些符号着迷，如果我让他们四处走动时看起来像那个包呢？
Dapper Dan didn't want to take designer bags and replicate them. I wanted to do something nobody else was even thought of. I got to figure out how to transform them symbols into garments. Dapper Dan wanted to take these symbols. The logos of this old luggage company who at that point really only made bags and he wanted to print them on clothing. I just started teaching myself, reading and going to trade chills,
Dapper Dan 不想拿设计师的包来复制它们。我想做一些别人甚至都没有想过的事情。我得想办法把这些符号变成服装。Dapper Dan 想要利用这些符号。这家老牌箱包公司的标志当时实际上只生产包，他想把它们印在衣服上。我刚开始自学，阅读并参加贸易展，
and so I taught myself everything. And Dapper Dan started to print Louis Vuitton logos on things that Louis Vuitton could have never dreamt of. Leather track suits, skin tight leather dresses, long bulletproof leather trench coats, full leather car interiors, as well some totally original designs. Like Dabrdan created this particularly distinctive jacket with a black fur torso and huge puffy leather balloon sleeves covered in LVs. And he started using the logos of other legacy luxury brands and fancy cars and religious
所以我自学了一切。Dapper Dan 开始在路易威登做梦也想不到的东西上印上路易威登标志。皮革运动服、紧身皮裙、长款防弹皮风衣、全皮汽车内饰，以及一些完全原创的设计。就像 Dapper Dan 创作了这件特别独特的夹克，黑色皮草躯干和巨大的蓬松皮革气球袖，上面覆盖着 LV。他开始使用其他传统奢侈品牌、豪车和宗教的标志
totems. I made these buttocks of Jack as 30 years ago with the car logo's on them. His work was all festooned with symbols and it was all very expensive. Very expensive stuff. Very expensive stuff. Something about affordability leads to fashion demise. Even though he embossed his clothes with the marks of Gucci and Fendi and Louis,
图腾。我 30 年前制作了这些带有汽车标志的夹克。他的作品到处都点缀着符号，而且价格非常昂贵。非常昂贵的东西。非常昂贵的东西。价格实惠的东西会导致时尚的消亡。尽管他在衣服上印上了古驰、芬迪（Fendi）和路易威登的标志，
that was the only part of them that was actually a knockoff. Because nothing like these designs had ever existed before. Dapper Dan invented a genre. He is the creator of high-end hip-hop fashion. You come up with this idea, and this twist, and it becomes you. And so that's how I develop.
这实际上是它们唯一山寨的部分。因为以前从未存在过类似这些设计的作品。Dapper Dan 发明了一种流派。他是高端嘻哈时尚的创造者。你想出这个主意，这个转折，它就成了你。这就是我发展的方式。
I had to show them these brands that I could do and interpret them for my community, better than make it ever think of. All around him, MCs were remixing pop music into beats, and Dapper Dan was remixing established luxury brands, known symbols, into something entirely new. Dapper Dan is one of the reasons Logo Mania took off in the 80s. He was taking these brands away from their expected homes, on luggage or cars, and putting them all over bodies. If you look at old pictures of Missy Elliott or L.O. Cool J on YoMTV wraps, they're wearing
我必须向他们展示这些品牌，我能够做到这一点，并为我的社区解释它们，比他们想象的要好。在他周围，MC们正在将流行音乐重新混音成节拍，而 Dapper Dan 则将成熟的奢侈品牌、已知的标志重新混音成全新东西。Dapper Dan 是 80 年代 Logo 狂热兴起的原因之一。他把这些品牌从它们原本的家——行李箱或汽车上剥离下来，贴在身体各处。如果你看看 Missy Elliott 或 LL Cool J 在 YoMTV wraps 上的老照片，他们穿着
leather track suits covered with Gucci and Fendi logos, and those were not made by Gucci and Fendi. These designs were all original to Dapper Dan. People start seeing the outfits and starting seeing the wrappers without fit and they start going to ask Gucci, this I want them when I'm sober or I can't more and I want them when I'm so LL Cool J. That's what I definitely people start seeing.
印有古驰和芬迪标志的皮革运动服，而这些并不是古驰和芬迪制造的。这些设计都是 Dapper Dan 原创的。人们开始看到服装，开始看到穿着服装的说唱歌手，他们开始去问古驰，我清醒时或不能再多时想要这些，当我是 LL Cool J 时我想要这些。这就是我绝对人们开始看到的地方。
Oh, y'all did make this, it's coming from somewhere else. As Dapper Dan's clients spread out into the mainstream, as hip hop grew, the big fashion houses started to take notice of Dapper Dan and his trademark infringement. It started quietly at first, with covert agents visiting Dan's Harlem shop. They have to buy an agonement as evidence, take it to the courts,
哦，你们确实做了这个，它来自其他地方。随着 Dapper Dan 的客户进入主流，随着嘻哈音乐的发展，各大时装公司开始注意到 Dapper Dan 及其商标侵权行为。最初静悄悄地开始，卧底特工参观了丹在哈莱姆的商店。他们必须购买一份陈述作为证据，带到法庭上，
and the courts would grant them cease and desist order. But that for Dan did not cease nor desist. They don't want us looking like them. Touching their symbols. They send the marshes and they had the race to confiscate anything with their trademark on it. The federal marshals marched into dance shop with garbage bags. They came in waves. Gucci. Proud at. Fendi. And the marshals carted off thousands of dollars worth of dapper dance, custom work, and his equipment.
法院将批准他们发出停止并 desist 命令。但丹并未停止亦未 desist。他们不想让我们看起来像他们。触摸他们的符号。他们派马歇尔去没收任何带有他们商标的东西。联邦法警拿着垃圾袋走进丹的店铺。他们一波接一波地来。古驰。骄傲。芬迪。法警拉走了价值数千美元的 Dapper Dan 的定制作品和他的设备。
They kept raiding me and raiding me. How do I overcome this? How do I get around this? Why weren't you tempted to stop? Why wouldn't I stop? Yeah. Why should I stop? I didn't see no't you tempted to stop? Why were you not stop? Yeah. Why should I so? I didn't see no reason for me to stop. But weren't you scared about your business? Because I did. I mean, let's go back. I come from the poor
他们不断地突袭我，不断地突袭我。我该如何克服这个？我如何绕过这个？你为什么没有被诱惑停止？我为什么不停下来？是的。我为什么要停下来？我没有看到……你为什么没有被诱惑停止？为什么不停下来？是的。我为什么要这样？我没有看到任何让我停下来的理由。但你难道不担心你的生意吗？因为我确实担心。我的意思是，让我们回到过去。我来自贫穷
stable in Harlem. All I know is the system constantly stepping on me, stepping on me, stepping on us. You know? So it's like you had to learn to step back, figure out ways to navigate this system. That's the way I looked at it. It's another obstacle. Let's deal with it. Dapper Dan always knew what he was doing was illegal. Always. But he'd hang out with the law before in much more serious ways. He was used to hustling. So when the luxury brands came after Dan, he just found another way to go on.
哈莱姆的马厩。我所知道的就是这个系统不断地踩我，踩我，踩我们。你知道吗？所以这就像你必须学会退后一步，找出驾驭这个系统的方法。这就是我的看法。这是另一个障碍。让我们处理它。Dapper Dan 一直都知道自己在做违法的事。总是。但他在更严重的情况下与法律打过交道。他习惯了做生意。因此，当奢侈品牌追捕丹时，他找到了另一种继续前进的方法。
So I go on the ground. So what did that look like? That was hell. But it was necessary. Dapper Dan kept selling his work the way he used to sell his stolen clothes out of his car. He lived as a nomad. I went on the ground I had to make clothes and I would hit every black city from here to
所以我要地下。那是什么样子的？那是地狱。但这是必要的。Dapper Dan 继续以他以前在车里卖偷来的衣服的方式出售他的作品。他过着游牧的生活。我去了地下，我必须做衣服，我会从这里袭击每一个黑人城市
Chicago. Then come back and hit every black city from here to Atlanta. And that's sustained me for 20 years. 20 years away from the eyes of Gucci and Prada and all the major brands you would expect to get upset about trademark infringement and call in the federal marshals. The law was pretty cut and dry. As our expert, Professor Rusty Alla said, it's like a two-dimensional image. You can protect that.
芝加哥。然后回来攻击从这里到亚特兰大的每一个黑人城市。这维持了我 20 年。20 年来，远离古驰、普拉达（Prada）以及所有你期望对商标侵权感到不满并打电话给联邦法警的大品牌的视线。法律相当明确。正如我们的专家罗丝蒂阿拉教授所说，它就像一个二维图像。你可以保护它。
It seems pretty simple. But that's not how the law truly functions. When I think of a knockoff, I think of the imitation bags on Canal Street, I think of small vendors stealing the trademarks of huge companies. But big, wealthy, multinational fashion companies, knockoff small designers all the time, all the time. So the point where most of us might not realize we're buying knockoffs at all.
这看起来很简单。但法律的真正运作方式并非如此。当我想到山寨货时，我想到了卡纳尔街上的仿冒包，我想到了小商贩窃取大公司的商标。但是大而富有的跨国时装公司一直在山寨小设计师的设计，一直都在。以至于我们大多数人可能根本没有意识到我们在买山寨货。
When I first saw that I was like, you know, maybe it was a mistake. And then, maybe a mistake. Maybe I made a mistake in thinking that it was like too similar. You know, I was like, maybe they don't know. This is Tuesday, Basson. She's an illustrator. And that's how she got into the world of clothing.
当我第一次看到它时，我想，你知道，也许这是一个错误。然后，也许是一个错误。也许我误以为它太相似了。你知道，我想，也许他们不知道。这是 Tuesday Basson。她是一名插画家。这就是她进入服装界的方式。
I started making clothes when I moved to LA. At the time, I had put out a theme called Ugly Girl Gang, and the three girls on the front cover I had drawn were wearing satin jackets. And on the back of their satin jackets are hearts that say mixed emotions club. So many people would be like, oh, I would wear that jacket. And being in LA and being around clothing manufacturing, Mixed Emotions Club. So many people would be like, oh, I would wear that jacket. And being in LA and being around clothing manufacturing, I was like, maybe I can make that jacket.
我搬到洛杉矶时开始做衣服。当时，我发布了一个名为“丑女帮”（Ugly Girl Gang）的主题，我画的封面上的三个女孩穿着缎面夹克。在缎面夹克的背面是心形，上面写着“复杂情绪俱乐部”（mixed emotions club）。很多人会说，哦，我会穿那件夹克。身处洛杉矶，身处服装制造业，“复杂情绪俱乐部”。很多人会说，哦，我会穿那件夹克。身处洛杉矶，身处服装制造业，我想，也许我可以做那件夹克。
Tuesday made her first bomber jacket in 2015. It looked exactly like the one her character and her scene is wearing. It satin with a big heart across the back that says, mixed Emotions Club. It sold out, and I made some more. Tuesday went on to design an entire line of pins and patches and accessories and clothes
Tuesday 在 2015 年制作了她的第一件飞行员夹克。它看起来和她的角色在她的场景中穿的一模一样。它是缎面的，背面有一个巨大的心形图案，上面写着“复杂情绪俱乐部”。它卖光了，我又做了一些。Tuesday 接着设计了一整套胸针、徽章、配饰和服装
in a wide range of sizes. A lot of her illustrations are integrated into her clothing. So it's an extremely personal thing, which is why it was almost painful in 2016. When the fast-fashion behemoth Zara sold a line of designs that looked which is why it was almost painful in 2016. When the fast fashion behemoth Zara sold a line of designs that looked exactly like Tuesdays. It was my entire catalog of goods on their products,
尺寸范围广泛。她的许多插图都融入了她的服装中。所以这是一件极其个人的事情，这就是为什么在 2016 年几乎令人痛苦的原因。当快时尚巨头 Zara 出售一系列看起来……这就是为什么在 2016 年几乎痛苦的原因。当快时尚巨头 Zara 出售一系列看起来与 Tuesday 的一模一样的设计时。这是我产品上的整个商品目录，
on various products. Sure, it's patches, everything. This is illegal, especially since Tuesday had already registered her images. I am somewhat proactive about being litigious and already had portrayed Mark's on most of the designs. That's so smart. Yeah. So Tuesday did what you're supposed to do.
在各种产品上。当然，是补丁，一切。这是违法的，尤其是 Tuesday 已经注册了她的图像。我对诉讼相当积极，而且大多数设计都已经有了商标。太聪明了。是的。所以 Tuesday 做了你应该做的事。
She issued a cease and desist notice. I think the scariest thing about it is that in detects the parent company of Zara is the largest fast-facifation company in the world. Their founder, Amansi Ortega, at one point was actually the sixth wealthiest man on Earth. Accusing the largest brand in the world, right, largest fast-fashion brand in the world, of stealing my intellectual property is scary.
她发出了停止并 desist 通知。我认为最可怕的事情是，Zara 的母公司 Intertex 是世界上数一数二的快时尚公司。他们的创始人阿曼西奥·奥特加（Amancio Ortega）曾一度实际上是地球上第六富有的人。指控世界上最大品牌，对吧，世界上最大快时尚品牌偷窃我的知识产权是可怕的。
It's um, it's terrifying. In this David and Goliath story, Tuesday summoned all her courage and threw a stone at the giant. And Goliath didn't flinch. He barely even noticed. And got a letterback that it basically said like, we're big, you're little, like what do you want to do about it?
这嗯，这太可怕了。在这个大卫与歌利亚的故事中，Tuesday 鼓起所有的勇气，向巨人扔了一块石头。而歌利亚没有退缩。他甚至没有注意到。回信基本上说，我们很大，你很小，你想怎么样？
Nobody knows about who you are. When most people bought those Tuesday knockoffs from Zara, they had no idea they were knockoffs at all to fight for her own integrity. Tuesday filed suit against Intertex. Having a lawsuit is not very fun. Also, the legal costs mean nothing to Zara. To a small designer, it's considerable.
没有人知道你是谁。当大多数人从 Zara 购买这些 Tuesday 的山寨货时，他们根本不知道它们是山寨货，为了捍卫自己的尊严。Tuesday 对 Intertex 提起诉讼。打官司一点也不好玩。而且，诉讼费对 Zara 来说不算什么。对一个小设计师来说，这是相当可观的。
Good lawyers are so expensive. I mean bad lawyers are so expensive, you know. It's just exhausting to have to consistently defend what is legally yours. Tuesday's lawsuit eventually ended. God, last year. Yeah, so for years, it went on. The only thing Tuesday can legally say about the situation now is that it was resolved to their mutual satisfaction. Antichlomactic, I know. But the kicker is, it's not like Tuesday can relax now. Well, and absolutely it is happening again, actually, Bershka, another company
好律师太贵了。我的意思是坏律师太贵了，你知道的。不断地为原本属于你的东西辩护，实在是太累了。Tuesday 的诉讼最终结束了。天哪，去年。是的，所以持续了好多年。Tuesday 现在能合法说的唯一一件事就是，双方达成了解，彼此满意。反高潮，我知道。但关键是，Tuesday 现在还不能放松。嗯，绝对正在发生，事实上，Bershka，Zara 母公司 Intatex 旗下的另一家公司，侵犯了其中一个相同的设计。不会吧。是的。一顶帽子上有一个小红心。里面写着“复杂情绪俱乐部”。这令人沮丧，而且令人精疲力竭。但我也觉得，如果我不继续捍卫我的品牌和我的知识产权
by Intatex who owns Zara, has infringed on one of the same designs. No way. Yeah. On a hat was a little heart. And inside it said, mixed emotions club. It's frustrating and it's exhausting. But I also feel like if I don't continue to defend my brand and defend my intellectual
财产，这种事会继续发生在我身上。它也会发生在其他人身上。这一直在发生，一直都在发生。每一个身处设计行业的人都知道这一点。以至于几乎无法避免。理论上，商标周围的规则应该是一种权衡。是的，这些法律可能会阻止像 Dapper Dan 这样的独立设计师重新混音其他人的图像，但这些法律也应该保护像 Tuesday 这样的设计师免受其原创图像被窃取。
property, this will continue happening to me. And it will happen to other people too. This happens all the time, all the time. Everyone working as a designer knows it. To the point where it's nearly unavoidable. In theory, the rules around trademark are supposed to be a bit of a trade-off. Yes, these laws might prevent independent designers like Dapper Dan from remixing other people's images, but these laws are also supposed to protect designers like Tuesday from having their original images ripped off.
而这些权宜之计根本不管用。更大、更富有的政党似乎总是赢。对于法律两侧的小设计师来说，这是毁灭性的。Tuesday 陷入了长达数年的诉讼，而 Dapper Dan 不得不隐姓埋名数十年。但这就是我对所遭遇的反对意见的反应。不要生气，因为他们对我做了这个，好吧？这就是你们做的。几十年。在地下度过 20 年，驾车穿过美国所有主要的黑人城市后，一些非常意想不到的事情将阿伯丁重新推回了聚光灯下。那是 2017 年 5 月，
And these stopgaps just aren't working. The bigger, wealthier party always seems to win. It's devastating for the little designer on either side of the law. Tuesday gets caught in litigation for years and years, and Dapper Dan has to go underground for decades. But that was my reaction to the opposition that I encountered. Not to get mad because they read it me, okay? This is what y'all do. decades. After 20 years underground, driving across all the major black cities in America, something really unexpected thrust Aberdeen back into the spotlight. It was May of 2017,
当古驰为他们的早春度假系列推出一款夹克时。这是一件非常独特的夹克，黑色皮草躯干和巨大的蓬松皮革气球袖，上面布满牛仔裤。这件夹克看起来几乎和 Dan 在 80 年代设计的夹克一模一样。真的就像一模一样。早在 80 年代。真的就像一模一样。如果你看一下 Dapper Dan 的原创夹克和古驰版本的夹克的照片，古驰非常明显地间接抄袭了他。百分之百绝对。与 Dapper Dan 过去的做法不同，古驰并不是将旧的东西重新混音成新的东西。他们只是制作了一个精确的复制品。虽然古驰可以对 Dapper Dan 叫来联邦法警，但 Dapper Dan 没有这个选择。并且它是
when Gucci sent a jacket down the runway for their cruise collection. It was a very distinctive jacket with a black fur torso and huge puffy leather balloon sleeves covered in jeans. This jacket looked almost exactly like a design Dan made back in the 80s. Really like identical. back in the 80s. Really like identical. If you look at the images of Dapper Dan's original and Gucci's version of the jacket, Gucci very obviously indirectly knocked him off. A hundred percent definitely. And unlike what Dapper Dan had been doing, Gucci wasn't remixing something old into something new. They just made an exact replica. And while Gucci could call the federal marshals on Dapper Dan, Dapper Dan didn't have that option. And it was
不是因为古驰很大而 Dapper Dan 很小。这是因为古驰的做法完全合法。美国系统中的设计是完全可复制的。古驰复制的不是二维图像。它不是标志或图案。他们复制的是服装的设计、形状、剪裁和材质。你完全可以这样做。美国时尚产业非常非常成功。
not because Gucci is big and Dapper Dan is small. It's because what Gucci did is perfectly legal. The design in the American system is fully copyable. Gucci wasn't copying a two-dimensional image. It wasn't a logo or a pattern. They were copying the design of the garment, the shape and the cut and the material. And you can totally just do that. The American fashion industry is very, very successful.
它赚了很多钱。它的影响力遍及全球。在过去的几十年里，它做得很好。然而核心理念、设计，可以被任何人复制。而且任何人都在复制它。如果你想出一个很酷的袖子或一个看起来非常不同的领子，在美国版权系统中你对它没有任何权利。如果你想出有用或技术创新的东西，
It makes a lot of money. It's worldwide in its reach. It's done very well over the last few decades. And yet the core idea, the design, can be copied by anyone. And it is copied by anyone. If you come up with a cool sleeve or a really different looking collar, you have no claim to it in the American copyright system. If you come up with something that's useful or technologically innovative,
比如也许它是一种新型的吸汗面料，也许你可以获得专利。理论上，比如一种独特的扣子，或者它可以申请专利。你知道，它必须是非显而易见的并且新颖的。获得专利的门槛要高得多。但除此之外，没有。所有设计都是公平的游戏。缺乏这种监管的论点是，它使时尚周期不断运转。
like maybe it's a new kind of sweat-wicking fabric, maybe you could get a patent. In theory, like a unique kind of toggle or it could be patented. You know, it has to be non-obvious and novel as a bunch of it. It's a much higher hurdle to get a patent. But otherwise, no. All designs are fair game. The argument for this lack of regulation is that it keeps the fashion cycle churning.
毕竟，潮流意味着每个人都在模仿的东西。新的风格激增并传播，我们都出去购物，新的风格激增并传播，我们都出去购物，新的风格激增并传播，我们都出去购物，新的风格激增并传播，我们都出去购物。是的，所以抄袭的作用是促进时尚周期，即某事物流行和过时的周期。它使这一过程能够更快地发展。Cala Rostiala 和他的合著者 Chris Sprigman 在他们的书《山寨经济》（The Knock-Off Economy）中提出了这个观点。在时尚界，每个人一直在互相抄袭，因为服装产业依靠由欲望和潮流蔓延混合而成的燃料运转。你可能会买一部新手机
After all, a trend means a thing that everyone is copying. New styles proliferate and spread and we all go out shopping and new styles proliferate and spread and we all go out shopping and new styles proliferate and spread and we all go out shopping and new styles proliferate and spread and we all go out shopping. Yes, so what copying does is enable the fashion cycle, so the cycle of something coming into fashion and going out. It enables that to move more quickly. Cala Rostiala and his co-author Chris Sprigman make this argument in their book, The Knock-Off Economy. In fashion, everyone copies each other all the time because the clothing industry runs on a fuel concocted of desire and trend proliferation. You might buy a new phone
每隔几年，因为技术在进步，但衬衫通常不会变得更好。随着你的品味改变而消费，设计师必须迎合你的喜好和潮流。所以他们互相偷窃。有时人们会持这样的看法，你知道，把跳跃当作成功的一部分。这是一件好事，或者它是以太的一部分，我们只是让它发生。
every few years because the technology improves, but shirts generally don't get better at shirting. You consume as your taste changes, and designers have to appeal to what you like and what style is in. And so they steal from each other. Sometimes people take the view of like, you know, hopping as they're on some of success. And it's a good thing, or it's part of the ether, we just let it happen.
当你是一家大公司时，这样做会容易一些。当你是一家小公司时，这就有点艰难了。每隔几年，就会提出新的立法，使美国时尚法更加严格，但总是无疾而终。拉斯蒂阿拉教授认为，原因在于时尚版权是一把双刃剑。如果你收紧规则来保护独立设计师，你也会收紧规则来保护大型时装公司，他们得到的收益远远大于失去的。
It's a little easier when you're a really big company to do that. When you're a small firm, it's a little tougher. Every couple of years, new legislation is brought forward to make American fashion law more strict, and it always falls through. And Professor Astiala argues that the reason is, fashion copyright is a double-edged sword. If you tighten up the rules to protect independent designers, you also tighten up the rules to protect major fashion houses, who stand to gain far more than they have to lose.
他认为，如果时尚版权的规定更严格或执行力度更大，它可能会产生奇怪的文化连锁反应。嗯，这其实是一个我不想居功的想法。这是我们在纽约大学的同事巴顿，认领这是我们在纽约大学的同事巴顿·比比（Barton BB），他真正首先谈到了这一点。但在过去，一些短暂的法典规定了谁可以穿什么，只有某些阶层的人才能穿某些服装。在一个时尚版权严格得多的世界里，更严格的时尚法可能就像现代避难所法典一样运作。
He argues that if fashion copyright was written more strictly and or enforced more heavily, it could have odd cultural ripple effects. Well, this is really an idea that I don't want to claim. It's a colleague of ours at NYU, Barton, to claim it's a colleague of ours at NYU, Barton, BB who really first talked about this. But some shorty codes in the past dictated who could wear what, and only certain classes of people could wear certain clothing. And stricter fashion law could function like modern sanctuary codes in a world with much stricter fashion copyright.
如果你现在想穿一些新鲜、酷炫或时髦的东西，除非你想穿一些新鲜、酷炫或时髦的东西，否则你不能。除非你想花几百美元买一件正宗的引领潮流的设计师作品。即使你自己制作了版本，如果你缝制了一种特定类型的连衣裙或衬衫，灵感来自于你在 Instagram 上看到的东西，你也可能会因为侵权而被起诉。因此，我们目前享有的复制自由的伟大之处之一在于，它使每个人都能穿上设计。因此，如果出现了一个非常流行的设计，比方说，普拉达（Prada）以非常高的价格点推出，普通人，更不用说穷人了，永远买不起。
If you wanted to wear something new and cool or trendy right now, you couldn't unless you wanted to wear something new and cool or trendy right now, you couldn't. Unless you wanted to pay hundreds of dollars for the authentic trend-setting designer piece. Even if you made your own version, if you sowed a particular kind of dress or blouse inspired by something you saw on Instagram, you could be sued for infringement. And so one of the great things about the freedom to copy that we currently have, is it enables everyone to wear designs. So if a really popular design comes out of, let's say, product at a very high price point, the average person, let alone a poor person, could never afford it.
但山寨设计的能力意味着他们也可以穿上该设计并获得它。虽然，我们不要把商品的民主当作真正的民主形式，你知道，我们的世界已经分裂成了阶层。坐公交车的人和坐顺风车的人，头等舱、商务舱和超长腿部空间。那些真正买得起 2,000 美元包的人和那些在卡纳尔街买包的人。那些大到足以保护自己的作品的设计师和那些不能的设计师。
But the ability to knock off the design means that they too can wear that design and they have access to it. Although, let's not take a democracy of goods as an actual form of democracy, you know our world is already fractured into tears. People who take the bus and people who take a lift, first class, business class, and extra legroom. Those who can actually afford a $2,000 bag and those who buy them on Canal Street. The designers who are big enough to protect their work and those who aren't.
那么，当你看到他们使用你的……时，你生气了吗？不，我预料到了。甚至直到今天。我从来没有指望人们会为你演奏。Dapper Dan 本人已经习惯了不公正。但是一旦古驰夹克的照片在互联网上流传开来，黑人推特就说，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。就像推特爆红一样？我说，哇，这太有力量了？我以前从来没有过声音。在线时尚界对此感到愤怒。记得这件夹克的网民又把它翻了出来。Dapper Dan 几十年来第一次再次成为每个人口中的焦点。
So were you upset when you saw them using your... No, I expect that. I never even to this day. I never expect people to play for you. Dabberdan himself had grown accustomed to injustice. But as soon as photos of Gucci's jacket hit the internet, black Twitter was like, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Like Twitter hit? I said, wow, is that powerful? I never had a voice before. The online fashion world was outraged. People who remembered the jacket dredged it up again. And Dapper Dan was back on everyone's lips for the first time in decades.
然后所有的社交媒体开始爆发，人们来找我，询问所有这些时尚创意来自何处。一股互联网愤怒的洪流针对古驰抄袭 Dapper Dan 的行为。于是古驰做了一件非常非常聪明的事。仅仅几个月后，在 2017 年 12 月，他们就联系了 Dapper Dan。他们为丹提供了一个设计师的职位，但拥有完全绝对的自主权。这闻所未闻，对吧？现在 Dapper Dan 正在做他以前做的事。仍然在试验、重新混音并制作非常昂贵的定制服装，除了现在他
And then all the social media started hitting and people came for me with where all this fashion ideas came from. A torrent of internet outrage was directed towards Gucci for copying Dapper Dan. And so Gucci did something very, very smart. They reached out to Dapper Dan only a few months later in December of 2017. And they offered Dan a position as a designer, but with complete and absolute autonomy. That's unheard of, right? Now Dapper Dan is doing exactly what he did before. Still experimenting and remixing and making very expensive custom garments, except now he
只能使用古驰标志。他在哈莱姆的工作室前面有一个小的古驰标志。所以大人物还是赢了，但他们让 Dapper Dan 加入了俱乐部。因为 Dapper Dan 是 20 世纪最具影响力的人物之一。他是一个成功的故事。他是一个名字。换句话说，他是一个品牌。所以当然，人们在模仿他。
can only use Gucci symbols. And his Atelier in Harlem has a little Gucci sign out in front. So the big guy still kind of wins, but they've let Dapper Dan into the club. Because Dapper Dan is one of the most influential minds of the 20th century. He's a success story. He's a name. In other words, he's a brand. So of course, people are knocking him off.
文达（Vindas）跑过来向我展示他们亲自模仿的东西。等等，真的吗？是的。不会吧。确实如此。确实如此。你看到的时候怎么想？我该怎么想？
Vindas run up to me and show me they knock off that but they did personally. Wait really? Yes. No way. Yes way. Yes way. What do you think when you see that? What should I think?
我该说些什么？听着，我是一个人。古驰是一个跨国公司，芬迪和所有这些跨国公司。他们无法停止。这是会发生的事情。你知道我在说什么吗？你顺其自然吧。当然，顺其自然。在我们热爱的事物上画着一幅肖像。
What should I say? Look, I'm one guy. Gucci's a multinational corporation, Fendi's and all these multinational corporations. They can't stop. It is something that's going to happen. You know what I'm saying? You just let it be. Let it be of course. There's a portrait painted on the things we love.
《感兴趣的物品》（Articles of Interest）由艾弗里·特劳夫曼（Avery Truffleman）编剧并主持，克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）剪辑，埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）协助剪辑，雷·皇家（Ray Royal）配乐，汤姆·科利根（Tom Colligan）核实事实，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）协助核实事实。混音和技术制作由谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Yusef）负责，凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Catherine Rae Mondo）和肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）协助混音。我们的开场曲和闭幕曲由萨萨米（Sassami）创作，本集特别感谢克里斯·斯普里格曼（Chris Sprigman）和阿里尔·阿拉亚（Ariel Alaya），整个 99PI 团队提供了深刻的见解支持和编辑，包括乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、薇薇安·勒（Vivian Le）、艾比·马丹（Abby Madan）、库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）、德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）和凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）。
Articles of Interest was written and performed by Avery Trouffleman, edited by Chris Baroube with additional editing by Emmett Fitzgerald, scored by Ray Royal, fact checked by Tom Colligan with additional fact checking by Graham Haysha. Mix and tech production by Sharif Yusef with additional mixing by Catherine Rae Mondo and Sean Rial. Our opening and closing songs are by Sassami, special thanks this episode to Chris Sprigman and Ariel Alaya, Insight support and edits from the whole 99PI team, including Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Le, Abby Madan, Kurt Colstead, Delaney Hall, and Katie Mingle.
罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）是整个系列的正宗核心。我试着描绘我们热爱的事物。所以我们大多数人买不起一整套设计师服装。所以你可能会从同一个品牌买一些所谓更便宜的配饰，比如手提包或太阳镜。但接触一个品牌最便捷的方式可能是一瓶香水。因为对大多数人来说，买一双 2,000 美元的鞋子非常非常困难。
And Roman Mars is the real McCoy of this whole series. I'm trying to paint in the things we love. So most of us can't afford an entire designer outfit. So you might buy some quote unquote cheaper accessories from the same brand, like a handbag or sunglasses. But the most accessible way to a brand is probably a bottle of perfume. Because it's very, very difficult for most people to buy a $2,000 pair of shoes.
几乎每个人都买得起 85 美元的香水。钱德勒·伯尔（Chandler Burr）是《完美的香味》（The Perfect Scent）一书的作者，也是《纽约时报》的前香水评论家。设计师和时装品牌意识到，他们可以创造出这些东西，它们将成为品牌的完美象征，而不必降低连衣裙、鞋子和所有其他东西的价格，但他们可以拥有一部分
Almost everybody can afford an $85 bottle of perfume. Chandler Burr is the author of the perfect scent and the former perfume critic for the New York Times. Designers and fashion labels realized that they could create these things and they would be the perfect emblem of the brand where they didn't have to lower their prices of their dresses and their shoes and all that other stuff, but they could have a piece
这个品牌面向大众受众。香水是一个庞大的产业。香水是世界历史上创造的最有效的机器，可以将品牌和名气转化为现金。它很私密，你把它穿在皮肤上，你知道，它甚至比衣服还要私密。它与品牌或名人联系在一起。其中有一种亲密感。
of the brand that was accessible to a mass audience. Perfume is a massive industry. Perfume is the most efficient machine ever created in the history of the world for turning brand and fame into cash. It is intimate, you wear it on your skin, you know, and it's more intimate than clothing even. It's associated with a brand or with a famous person. There isn't intimacy there.
但这并不是说这些品牌或名人在自己混合他们的标志性香味。你下一个感兴趣的物品是香水。你下一个感兴趣的物品是香水。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子发表评论。
But it's not like these brands or famous people are mixing their signature sense themselves. Your next article of interest is perfume. Your next article of interest is perfume. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但这些品牌或名人并不是自己调制其标志性气味的。你下一个感兴趣的物品是香水。你下一个感兴趣的物品是香水。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。